It. Who own these fish took me down.
Deep and obviously snagged up somewhere
. I had to cutting off but i saw what the
hell would be down there from the bottom
of this war and then while i was rigging
up again looking around there were lumps
of granite lying around covered in the
grass and so on. And it suddenly dawned on
me. This was the wharf where the granite
for the sydney harbour bridge pylons were
shipped from and afterwards i told the wife
about this and we looked around and you
could see blocks of granite lying
around on the verges of the quarry and
it certainly brought back the fact that
yes i had been there when this stuff was
being delivered in sydney. What fifty odd
years back. Do you know that quarry was
used after the sydney harbour bridge. I
don't really know it was beautiful granite
very tough stuff. And i'm not
certain i do think it was used on
a few buildings but i couldn't i couldn't
be certain of this. Did you take any of
the photographs for the the cenotaph the
cutting of the stones for the senator. No
no i never did. Is that the same stone.
It's the same stone it was cut at the same
quarry and there was also public works
pictures of the opening of the cenotaph in
martin place so i didn't know whether you
you were there at all. Now i left. Bob
bad and actually before the bridge where
it was foundation and went into newspapers
. But on the day the bridge was opened. I
wasn't up on the roadway i was down in
the launch on the harbour doing the
covering the procession of the overseas and
interstate ships coming through
under the archway. Did you get
a shot of the planes as well.
I think could have done
a forgotten how i think smithy's
playing was flew over in
a few air force and other planes but
actually my memory is much clearer of the
magnificent side of these i think there
are about seven or eight of them. The
liners coming through it was
a magnet and of course they were all decked
out in their flags and everything and
it was a magnificent sight it was
a beautiful day you were there working on
that day were you for the newspapers. Yes
yes that was so but i didn't see any of the
gory degree of an intern end or any of
that. Do you remember the workshops.
When you went photograph them there.
Oh yes indeed. Because the noise in there
was terror efik the riveting going on and
. Although they were huge workshops
they were always know is
a hit and dirty and if the southerly was
blowing clouds of dirt and dust used to
come through the doors and windows. Yes i
member those. When you took photographs.
Did you take any photographs of people
riveting in the workers. Yes we did. And of
course also on the bridge itself
but mostly i work was more general
and jan in detail and we weren't so
concerned with. Actual workers in close
up and that type of thing not working
methods but engineering detail. That's
correct yes. He went to work in
melbourne on newspapers will
you ever out of work when you were when you
were in between newspapers or something
. Yes but before going to melbourne. I
went on newspapers in sydney and i joined
the old telegraph victoria when it was in
the trust building in. In king street and
then that folded up and then i went to
the data gardening which was part of the
smiths weekly group. I was there for some
years and then that was sold out to the
sun. And rather the evening
news which is part of the sun
just previously bought. I wasn't there
very long and that folded up. And. These
were the days when
a man would say love his home and
go into state for another pound
a week and they were very grim. But
i battled around with a camera made
a few bob but those were the days if
you could make three or four pound
a week. You could live. Not well but you
could live what you freely do freelance
photography doing that. Yes. Anywhere
you could make it crashed. And then
gradually things improved.
And i went to melbourne on
a freelance basis for two rather odd
newspapers. I went for the women's weekly
and also for the smiths weekly group
being paid
a retainer by both of them smiths weekly
in those days had the referee which was
a sporting paper. So i would cover sporting
events and i and races in. In melbourne
for them. And the women's weekly was
trying to break further into the melbourne
victorian scene and i would cover social
and any local stories for them and it
worked at it quite
a good basis until i was thinking about
getting married. The wife and i were
engaged for five years and you couldn't
dream of getting married. Those days but.
The argus in melbourne was starting an
evening paper. And frank davison who
i'd known on the guardian in he'd married
the first missile stray lia berra meals
happened a bumpy one night in
a picture show and bourke street and
he said my god we're looking for
a photographer's bill for god sake
come and join us. It was going to be
a pictorial tabloid. So i
thought well why not give it
a go and i want to get married and although
i was making better money than they
offered me i had a feeling it was too
good to last and i thought a staff job on
a newspaper would prove more sensible
and so this i did and we got married in
melbourne later of course there were
signs that the star was going to go.
And i was offered
a job at the melbourne herald and i spent
some years there with them. Remember
years and smiths weekly.
Oh yes indeed it was
a wonderful period of time there are
some wonderful characters working there
because they are the greatest black and
white staff ever assembled i think anywhere
in the world. At that period. Follows
like frank done. Stand cross
said and miller. Or molly horseman
joe johnson. I can't you know
memory one let me recall them all.
Finally i would george was their course
it's time to recall the
names of them now but
i was trying to think of the tall thin
x digger who did the digger cartoons
. And i can't for the moment. Think of his
name but it will come to me. Could he
remember any chance about the times you
worked at smith wheatley well the us
and i told you there's
a very odd characters there
virgil reilly was there. Verge of
a stamos for his drawings of females. The
joint smith was quite
a character he used to buzz in and out of
the place. Never seemed to take an active
interest much in it. Boss's them
were robert clyde packer and
he was
a wonderful followed to work for the they
had
a great staff there knows days and although
they were battling it was still the depression
years. Do you remember how much
you got paid when you worked as
a photographer assistant at the public
works. From memory i think it was about
thirty five thirty seven shillings
a week. I don't i think
three pound a week then was
a very good wage. You were asking
me about bob bowed and well bob was
a as i mentioned before a very
dedicated photographer. He was
a man who i've seen him come back from
a trip in the country where he be
photographing the mayor and jack dam or
a van dam or cordo dam which were all being
built at that period and he'd been away
for probably
a week or so and he comes to come back and
start processing into negatives and he
was a great believer that negatives had
to be thoroughly washed be due to he had
a great sense of did anything it was
a took was for official records and had
to have permanency and the only day in
those days only way to ensure permanency
was by thoroughly washing your plates and
negatives and he would stay back at night
and sit down and wait for an hour or two
of these plates were thoroughly washed and
he would never dream of short changing
the tide where anything
like that. Is he was
a hard man to work for
in the sense that he had
a high quality standard. But
he was
a man who knew what he wanted and i often
felt that if i had any character building
as
a photographer he did more for me than anyone
else i ever worked with or for afterwards
. Where did he get his training how
he cut is from digger tardy senior.
Who he'd spent his time
with as far as from
a young man. And of course back in those
days they were just emerging from the wet
plate stage. And decca tardy. We
still had there or the old equipment
there that they used to use they are
still go away with a horse and buggy and
a big black tent. Sensitize
the plates in the tent load
them into their big. Slides and expose
them while they were still damp and
process them in the field. And they is
amazing. The results they achieved under
those conditions. And i have great
admiration for for the work they were
doing but from what i was heard of decca
tati i never knew he died before my time
but he was
a man from which bob bowed and
had copied his dedication
. Do you know any other photographers of
the day. Well known photographers now
. Oh there was a hall in hunter street
a forgotten isn't is first name
now sam hood in pitts treat.
One of the one of the best of that area
of course was with the sydney morning
herald and the. The magazine they had
at that time sydney mail sydney mail.
Do you names. Do you remember. Milton. Kent.
Oh yes yes i knew. Milton. Well milton
had his own aeroplane. He was
a pioneer of aerial photography but his
main basis of that time was photographing
motorcars. He had
a dark room and i think one or two visions
in the business with him at five dock is
that's right. Her turn
of him being someone of
a wild man and buzzing everybody all inside.
Yeah by the course those were the days
when aviation was
a devil may care sort of
industry your occupation and
i have great memories of him
be cars. Where we were located
photographic section in the
works building. We had
a dark room on the roof and from our
windows up there you could look down into
macquarie street it looked down on
the conservatorium. And this was
a great spot for militant can't to photograph
his motor cars and we would often see
milton can down there were five or six cars
lined up waiting to be photographed and
of course these were the stand camera plate
glass negatives days and. It wouldn't
be
a quick snapshot job it was you know it took
time. And i'm out i met milton many times
either very likeable
fellow very likeable is
a business is still going and all is old
glass negatives are still available. Is
that so areas son still in the business or
you know his son is out of the business
and he's sold it to
a couple of polish photographers who still
carry on the business and have the all
the glass negatives. When he
was a neighbor's another is
a magnificent photographer that period.
Do you remember another fellow who was
a doctor i believe he's doing real photo
photographs doctoring. Then the much
larger hour can't exactly remember
his no no no. I remember r.p.
More now. No i didn't know him. Maybe
studios know i knew he'd be studios but i
know the name more but i didn't know him
personally. I was trying to think of the
pilot who flew in the early days
with smith the original. Airlines
they were operated. He ran
a photographic business into partnership
with i think it was followed
of
a disaster airways. Gene names. Mr. Astra
reprogram fix are still going instantly
also. Yes well i haven't heard of them for
some years i know they were going some years
back. But the name of trying to think
of talking from the sydney mail
was burt fishwick he was he was
a magnificent photographer. And any of
the oil boys will all remember him with
great admiration and respect. Can i
take you back to the the large in
room on top of the on top of the public
works building exactly how did you do in
those days we had of either complicated
set up. We had an all or lantern type
enlarger. Which was set on four legs
with
a tank of oil which held about twenty gallons
of oil heavy oil. Suspended under it
and. During the exposure. If the
contraption would bump that or
the oil absorbed the vibration and
didn't spoil your exposures and we had
a. A glass. Opal glass piece of
glass set into the wall of the dark room.
Which gave us our daylight for enlarging
and outside we were direct
a sheet of canvas on
a stretcher which was which would help to
watch the word for it. Diffuse while diffuse
the light and also throw it back to
the window and the actual exposure
was made from your daylight and
if it was cloudy conditions. You'd have
to duck out and sign outside and have
a quick look and see if they was a
cloud coming up because it would make
a vast difference to bougie but by this
complicated method it was amazing. The
quality of the enlargements that were
made and that time there was just no
artificial light used in your enlargements
at all. Now no artificial lights used
because in those days you didn't have
the globes that gave you the. The type
of light you required the electric lamps
you know. And although they came in
a few years afterwards and they used
a condenser which would break down any
distortion from the filaments of the lamps
and sort of even it out in the light at.